[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء معكم راويه القاسم نبداوها بالعربي
مع استمرار يفرز الاصوات تقدم الحزب
الجمهوري في مجلس النواب والشيوخ
وتوقعاتهم بان تكون جورجيا ورقه الحزمه
انسحاب مفاجئ للقوات الروسيه من خرسون
المنطقه الوحيده التي سيطرت عليها بالكامل
منذ بدء الهجوم في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لاول مره منذ بدء الاحتجاجات جبهه اصلاحيه
داخل ايران تدعو السلطات لاجراء استفتاء
لاخراج البلاد من اثمتها
كبار ومواقع التواصل يا النون بعد تويتر
متى تصرح احد عشر الف موظف بعد خسرتها
مليارات الدولارات هذا العامه
[موسيقى]
اذا يستمر فرز الاصوات في الولايات
المتحده لتحديد الفائزين في ابرز المناصب
التشريعيه بعد يوم حافل ادلى فيه
المقترعون باصواتهم لاختيار 36 حاكما و35
عضوا لتجديد ثلث مجلس الشيوخ
و435 عضو في تجديد كامل لمجلس النواب
اليكم مشاهدينا ابرز النتائج حتى الان وما
حصل عليه الحزبان الجمهوري والديمقراطي
وفقا لما نقلته وكاله مستشفيه في مجلس
الشيوخ الحزب الذي يسعى الى الاغلبيه
يحتاج 51 مقعدا من اصل 100 مقعد الحزب
الجمهوريه اصبح يشغل 49 مقعدا حتى الان اذ
فاز
انيقه 10 مقعدا بينما يشغل 29 اخرين خارج
الانتخابات في حين خسر مقعدا واحدا لصالح
الديمقراطيين حتى الان ابرز الفائزين
الجمهوريين السيناتور رن جونسون الذي خاض
معركه صعبه للحفاظ على مقعده في ويسكنزون
وتتباد في ولايه نورس كارولينا
وجيدي فانس عن ولايه اوهايوط اما الحزب
الديمقراطي في يملك 48 مقعدا الى الان في
مجلس الشيوخ حيف ضمن اثنا عشر مقعدا مضيفا
مقعدا واحدا ابرز الفائزين من
الديمقراطيين ماجي حسن عن ولايه نيو هشام
شعائر
من سلفانيا بالنسبه لمجلس النواب من يسعى
للوصول الى الاغلبيه من الحسبين عليه
تحصيل 2008
الحزب الجمهوريه ضمن حتى الان
2003 من المقاعد دون ان سرق ايمن قعد اما
الحزب الديمقراطي فتمكن من الفوز ب
187 مقعدا الا انه خسر مقعدين ذلك بحسب سي
ان ان اما فيما يتعلق بحكام الولايات
فيمتلك الحزب الجمهوري حتى الان 24 ولايه
حيث خسر اثنتين وفاز بسته عشر في حين يحكم
ثماني ولايات لا تشملها الانتخابات في
المقابل الحزب الديمقراطي يحظى حاليا
باثنتين و20 ولايه هيكتسبه ولايتين وفاز
بخمسه عشر في حين يحكم ستويات لا تشملها
الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
وتنضمام
العربيه
وايضا من واشنطن ناديه قلب البيسي اهلا
بكما معي
ناديه يعني كيف تسير الامور مع استمرار
عمليات الفارس
انتقل الى الزميله ريتا يبدو ان ناديه
ليست جاهزه كيف هي الاوضاع عن ذكرته
باختصار عمليات حسابيه كبيره
تجري الان في نيفادا مع انه المعلومات
الاوليه تشير الى تقدم المرشح الجمهوري
المرشح على عضو مجلس الشيوخ على منافسته
الديمقراطيه
همم ما يحصل تحديدا ان مقاطعه كلارك كلارك
كاونتي التي نتواجد فيها الان تضم 75% من
سكان نيفادا ولكن هناك مقاطعه اخرى
همم
الجمهوري على نفسه الديمقراطيه حتى اللحظه
لازال هناك اصوات لم تحسب همم حتى الان
لانه بعد عالي لاول مره ولاول انتخابات
همم كان استخدمت ما يعرف بي يونيفرسال فوت
ميل ما يعني انه هناك اصوات همم تمكن همم
مواطنون نيفادا من التصويت همم خارج
نيفادا وبالتالي هذه الاصوات لا زالت حتى
اللحظه لم تحسم بعد ومن المتوقع ان يتم
احتسابها في الايام المقبله او على ابعد
تقدير يوم السبت المقبل انتقل الى ناديه
كيف هي الاوضاع من عندك
وكان هناك ناديه همم توقعات بموجه حمراء
حسب ما ذكرت عده استطلاعات راي لماذا هذا
التباين بين ما تقوله همم استطلاعات الراي
وما تقوله الان صناديق الاقتراع بانه
الفارق بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين ليس
بكبير
هذا صحيح هو في الواقع ليست المره الاولى
التي تثبت استطلاعات راي بانها غير دقيقه
هذا ما حدث في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
السابقه وبالتالي لا يمكن الاعتماد عليها
بشكل كبير كان هناك الحديث على ان
الاقتصاد والتضخم والمشاكل التي يعاني
منها الرئيس بايرن ستؤثر بشكل اساس على
قرار الناخب الامريكي لكن يبدو بان ما
قاله بيدن والبيت الابيض والديمقراطيين
بان موضوع الديمقراطيه على انها في خطر
وبانه هناك مجموعه من مؤيدي الرئيس ترامب
يريدون ربما ان يختطفوا هذه الجلده وان
يشكك دوما في نزاهه الانتخابات عدا عن
موضوع الاجهاض على اعاده عن التخويف من
موضوع الضمان الاجتماعي الذي سيتحكم به
الجمهوري همم باغلبيه كبيره في مجلس
النواب اثر على الناخذ المستقل
يعني الناخب المصنف حسبيا منتمي لديم مين
او جمهوريه لن يغير رايه لكن الذي يؤثر في
هذه الانتخابات هو الناخب المتردد او
النسب المستقل الذي بالفعل تاثر بما قاله
الديمقراطيه وعكس ما التتبي استطلاعات
الراي وهو اننا سنرى اغلبيه كبيره في مجلس
النواب لصالح الجمهوريه لا نريد ان نؤكد
بان الجمهوريه قد يسيطرون على مجلس الا
اذا كانت هناك مفاجات في اللحظه الاخيره
يعني قبل ان نكون معك على الهواء اخر فرز
عمليه فرز هزاعبيه هي 203 لصالح اي
جمهوريه و187 لصالح الديمقراطين طبعا
جمهوريين بحاجه الى 2008
مقعد حتى يفوز بالاغلبيه لكن لن يحصل على
الاغلبيه المتوقعه وهي ربما 20 او 30 مقعد
يمكن ان تعطيهم اريحيه وبالمقارنه على
فكره مع الرئيس السابق ترامب رئيس اوباما
الرئيس بالفعل قبل بلاء حسنا يعني بالنسبه
همم حزبي ان يفوز او يحافظ على نسبه همم
ربما مع خصومه همم من الفوز يحصرها في
نسبه ضئيله هذه يعتبر فوز للرئيس بايدل
الذي قرر قبل قليل البيت الابيض اعلم بانه
سيجري مؤتمر صحفي الساعه الرابعه بتوقيت
واشنطن ليتحدث بالدرجه الاولى على
الانتخابات الامريكيه كان البيت الابيض
يتهرب ربما من محاوله طرحه ال- ال-
الصحفيين على بايدي لانهم كانوا يتخوفون
بعض كثير بالفعل الموجه الحمراء التي
سترتاح مجلس النواب هذا لم يتحقق حتى الان
حتى ذلك الوقت تكون نتائج لم تظهر بشكل
كامل صحيح
صحيح خصوصا في مجلس الشيوخ يعني في مجلس
الشيوخ على احسن الاحوال يمكن ان نعود الى
نقطه الصفر بمعنى بان الديمقراطين يحصلون
على 50 مقاعد والجمهورين على 50 وهو الامر
الحالي حاليا لكن هيئه الرئيس هي التي
تساوي طبعا مع الديمقراطين يعطيهم افضليه
ب 51 50 لذا سننتظر جورجيا هذه الولايه
التي دائما
لا تحسم الانتخابات في اليوم الاول خلال
الساعه سيكون هناك مؤتمر صحفي من مسؤولين
الانتخابات سنعرف اذا كان سيكون هناك جوله
اعاده في السادس من ديسمبر ام لا لكن ربما
اريزونا ونفادا سنعرف الليل وبالتالي حتى
لو ننتظر النتائج في جورجيا يمكن ان نقول
بان الديمقراطين يعولون عليها كثيرا هم
بحاجه الى انتزعاج جوجل ليعود مره اخرى
الى 50 لكن باقي الولايات اعتقد باننا
سنعرف في مجلس النواب الليله همم
هل ستحسم طبعا التوقعات الجمهوريه لكن
باغلبيه بسيطه جدا ريتا اود ان اسالك عن
نبض الشارع الان كان هناك اجماع همم بكل
همم ان كان استطلاعات الراي او المقابلات
مع الناس بانه همهم الوحيد هو اا موضوع
التضخم ارتفاع اسعار الوقود داخل الولايات
المتحده ولكن ما الذي ينتظرونه من ان كان
جمهوريين او حتى الديمقراطيين همم
بالنتائج يعني ما الذي ينتظرونه بما يخص
المواضيع المعيشيه اقصد طبعا
نعم
الاقتصاد هو الهم الوحيد للمواطن في
نيفادا كاو نيفادا
اقتصادها مبني على القطاع السياحي وتاثر
كثيرا ان كان من خلال رائحه كورونا ولم
يتمكن من التعافي من بعدها بسبب التضخم ما
يطلبونه هو قوانين اكثر ليونه تسمح
بانتعاش اقتصادي لهذه الولايه كما اا انه
هناك ايضا مطالب بما خص الوظائف وغيرها
وايضا واهم ما يؤرق المواطن في نفاذه هي
اسعار الوقود يطالبون ب همم ربما تحسينها
لاستهلاكات افضل ولا ننسى بانه هناك قطاع
صناعي في نيفادا كان تاثر ايضا ولكن هناك
مطالب بتحسين ومن همم همم من منتخبوهم في
هذه الانتخابات شكرا جزيلا لك لتسليمان من
لاس فيغاس ولك ايضا ناديه قلب البي سي من
العاصمه واشنط
[موسيقى]
هي البرلمانيه الاولى لكنها لن تكون
الاخيره مقوله اشتهرت بها جنات رانكن اول
امراه امريكيه تنتخبوا لعضويه الكونغرس
استخدمت خلال دورتين سلميه الصوت النسائي
في التصويت على قرارات الحرب لكنها فشلت
في تسجيل خلق مبقيه على انجازها الاهم
بتمثيل المراه ودعمها في المعتركين
السياسي والاجتماعي
ليه 227 عاما بعد تاسيسه ظل الكونجرس
الامريكي الذكوريه الحضور والتمثيل حتى
اخترق جدرانه صوت انثوي تمثل بعضويه جانا
ترين عام
انجاز غير مسبوق حققته ركن كاول امراه
تدخل لاروقه الكونجرس حامله بيدها صوتا
يمثل النساء اللواتي دعمها للترشح والفوز
بالمقعده حيث انتخبت ممثله الحزب الجمهوري
عن ولايه مونتانا بعد عملها للسنوات
كناشطه حقوقيه ومطالباتها بحق الانتخاب
للمراه الامريكيه
عقب وصولها لمجلس النواب باربعه ايام شكلت
الصوت الرافده لدخول بلادها غماره الحرب
العالميه الاولى مفضله الحياد وذلك بعد
تقدم الرئيس ودرو ويلسون بمشروع لاعلان
الحرب على المانيا غير ان
373 نائبا صوتوا لصالح الحرب لتاتي
الاصوات الخمسون الاخرى ومن ضمنها صوت ركن
خجوله ركن وصلت اثناء بقيه فترتها
كبرلمانيه الدفاع عن حق الانتخاب للامريات
كما دعم التمريره بعض القوانين الاجتماعيه
لصالح المراه والطفل لكن التصويت ضد الحرب
اغلق مصيرها السياسيه فشلت بالترشح لمجلس
الشيوخ عام
وغادرت مجلس النواب بعد عام واحد
شعبيه تورانكن بالساحه النسائيه اخذتها
برحله ثانيه الى الكونجرس عام 1940 لتصطدم
حين هكذا بقرارات مصريه التزمت فيها مجددا
بالسلميه لا اخرى على قرار دخول الحرب ضد
اليابان اثر الهجوم على بيرهابر
حاله استثنائيه شكلتها
تفردا تصويتها ضد كلتا الحربين لكنها كانت
لتصبح اكثر شرا لو اعطيت وقت اطول وابقى
اقوالها
[موسيقى]
تتقيد القرارات العسكريه للرئيس الامريكي
الى حد كبير في حاله خساره حزبه الاغلبيه
في غرفتي الكونجرس الشيوخ والنواب بماذا
يخبرنا التاريخ و عن علاقه الحروب التي
كانت الولايات المتحده طرفا فيها او دائما
لاحد الخصوم والانتخابات التشريعيه
[موسيقى]
انتخابات التجديد النصفي تتزامل مع الحرب
في اوكرانيا التي قوضت اقتصاد العالم 30
انتخابات النصفيه الجاره في القرن الماضي
في الولايات المتحده تزامل بعضها مع حروب
او نزاعات عسكريه شاركت فيها امريكا بشكل
مباشر او غير مباشر وانعكست على نتائجها
في الاثني عشر جوله من جولات التجديد
النصفي التي خسرها حزب الرئيس
الحربان العالميتان القطا بظلالهما
القادمه على الاقتصاد الامريكي كانت
المحصله خساره الحزب الديمقراطي اغلبيه
مجلس الشيوخ النواب في استحقاقي تجديد
النصفي عام
1918 و 20 294
اثناء سيطرته على الرئاسه الامريكيه عام
و990 وهي الانتخابات التي جرت بالتزامن مع
الحرب السوفيتي على افغانستان والحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه
صحيح ان هاتين الحربيين لم تتدخل فيهما
واشنطن بشكل مباشر الا ان دعمها لاحد
طرفيها لم يتوقف ابدا فتره حكم بوش الام
اما العام 2002 وكان الوضع استثنائيا خلال
المده الاولى لبوش الابن وفي اعقاب هجمات
ال 11 من سبتمبر تجمع الاميركيون خلف حزب
الرئيس وفاز الجمهوريون باغلبيه بسيطه
بلغت ثمانيه مقاعد في مجلس النواب لكن
لاحقا على جورج بوش الابن نفس معاناه ابيه
ففي اول انتخابات عقبه حربي العراق
وافغانستان خاسره حزبه الجمهوري اغلبيه
الكونجرس بغرفتي في انتخابات عام 2006
راحوا لهذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
الدكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه اهلا بك دكتور وليد
معنا الليله يعني كيف اثرت ملفات الحرب
الاوكرانيه والدعم الامريكي اللامحدود على
راي ومزاج الناخب الامريكي وايضا العلاقه
المتوتره مع الصين
كل الامور التي تتعلق بالعلاقات الخارجيه
والدبلوماسيه وحتى الحروب التي هي خارج
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وان كانت
هنالك مساعدات امريكيه لها بغض النظر عن
حروب الدفاعيه كما حصل بعد 11 ايلول 2001
او بعد اي حرب العالميه الثانيه حيث
للواشنطن وقتها دعم شعبي داخلي كل ما هو
عدد ذلك يمكن للمعارضه ان تستفيد منه
وتستعمله في دوله ديمقراطيه منفتحه
الاعلام لكي تنتقد الاداره وهذا ما حدث
عندما تفضلتم بهذا الفيلم الوثائقي في كل
مره دخلت الاداره الادارات امريكيه الحروف
ورجعت وانتهت هذه الحروب تستفيد المعارضه
بالانتقاد بالنسبه لليوكران
هنالك فريق يدعم الرئيس وهو ثنائي الحزبيه
يعني جزء من الحسبه جزء حتى الحزب جمهوري
يريد دعم اوكراني ولكن هنا في الديمقراطي
وفي الجمهوري يعارضان حتى دعم اوكرانيا
الم يكن يجب لي الحزب الجمهوري ان يستغل
اكثر ربما النتائج ما حصل او همم هذا
الدعم الذي فيه انتقادات او التململ
الامريكي حتى الشعبي من الدعم المالي لا
محدود
لاوكرانيا يعني حتى الان النتائج متقاربه
جدا همم ما الذي لم يقدر الجمهوريون ان
يقنعوا به الشارع الامريكي بالتصويت له
استغلال الثغرات الضعف التي تعاني منها
هذه الاداره
لاضيق على نقطه مهمه بفهم كيف تشتري
الامور في الاليه السياسيه
الامريكيه يعني عندما نعتقد انه هذه حرب
في الخارج وعلى الحزب الجمهوري ان يستفيد
منها بمقدار ان يستفيد واحد بالمئه اثنين
بالمئه لانه ما يهم المواطن الامريكي
اليوم هو جايبته وهو القدره الماليه
والقدره الاقتصاديه والوصول بسلامه الى ما
يسمى الويكان هذا بكل صراحه يعني في 85
الى 90 بالمئه من الشعب الامريكي ولكن اذا
اثرت تلك الحرب وهذا كان بيت القصير على
انتاج النفط والعلاقات مع روسيا وكل ذلك
ادى الى التاثير في الاقتصاد الامريكي
وهذا ادى هذا سوف يعطي نتيجه للمعارضه وقد
تستعمل في المعارضه بقدر المستطاع ولكن
قدرت الحزب الجمهوري او حتى الحزب
الديمقراطي الى افهم هذه الرساله المعقده
لمئات ملايين الامريكيين ليست سهله
الدكتور وليد يعني معروف بانه هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه هي تمهيديه وتؤ
ثر الانتخابات الرئاسيه لاحقا كيف ينظر
بالمقابل الخارج الى هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه يعني دول الخليج
ايران الرئيس لينسكي ايضا وبوتن كيف
ينظرون الى نتائج ما ستتمخد عنه هذه
الانتخابات
الاكثريه في مجلس الشيوخ مجلس النواب بيت
واضحا الجمهوريون سوف ياخذون مجلس النواب
الموضوع سوف يكون حول بكم نائب كان صوت
مسافه بين الحسبان هذا بحداته مهم لان
مجلس النواب سيكون مصادر عليها من قبل
المعارضه الجمهوريه وفيما يتعلق بالمنطقه
اول ملف سوف يكون الملف الايراني
سوف يتصدى ويوقف او اي توقيع من قبل
الكونغرس يعني مجلس واحد من المجلس
بامكانه ان يوقف الموضوع طبعا ايران غير
مسروره وبالطبع حلفاء الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الاقليميه على راسهم فقير ولكن
ايضا التحالف العربي والمعارضه الايرانيه
هم يعني يعتبرون هذا الشيء جيد لانه
الاداره قد تتفاهم مع المعارضه انه اذا لم
نوقع هذا الاتفاق ربما ناخذ بعد الامور
الاخرى منكم على اجندتنا مجلس الشيوخ مهم
بالعلاقات الخارجيه لانه فيه يتم تعيين
السفراء وكبار الموظفين والمدراء وفيه
ايضا همم يتم يعني السياسات
حربا او لا هذا هذه المعركه سوف تحسن في
جورجيا وعندها نعرف اذا كان جمهوريها
عندهم قادره للتاثير او غير عندهم قادره
للتاخير شكرا
وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه
جوابات الرئيس الامريكي تفيض بما يعرقل
تقدم مسيرته السياسيه اكثر ما تقدمه
بالعمر فابدا في حاله بحث شبه دائمه عن
الحروف والتوظيفات الصحيحه لمسؤولين
وبلدان ما زاد من متاعب اداراته التي
تلاحقها اتهامات بالتقاعد الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
توليفه من زله اللسان والقدم غير مبشره
للرئيس الامريكي جو بينا وضعت ليقته
الذهنيه والبدنيه في خانه الشك واثرت على
صوره الاداره الديمقراطيه قبل انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه
قوي
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الامريكي دائما التلاحمه تتوه عنه
الاسماء والصفات الوظيفيه لاهم اعضاء
فريقته بالسيده الاولى احيانا اخرى
اعلام
[موسيقى]
مصافحه الهواء واستبدال سوريا بليبيا
والشعب الاوكراني بالايراني وغضب بوتن
لروسيا عناوين مجموعه هفواتنا تلاحق بيضا
وتلصق به صفات الخلف احيانا
لكنها لا تلخص متاعب بيضا جميعها
الاقتصاديه تمثلت بوصول معدلات التضخم
لاعلى مستوياتها منذ 40 عاما نتج عنها
ارتفاع تكلفه المعيشه وانهيار قيمتي
ومكاسب اجور جميع العاملين كما يؤخذ على
بيض كيفيه التعامل مع رائحه كورونا ابناء
بيضا الذين يخطئوا باسمائهم ايضا يضيفون
الى سلسله الاخفاقات هذه ونقاط الضعف
السياسي حيث يخضع نجله هنتر لتحقيقات
فيدراليه منذ اربعه اعوام على خلفيه تهمي
فساد
تلاقي ببيانات كذبه لشراء سلاح
تصويت عقبي ينتظر صاحب 99 عاما في
الانتخابات النصفيه اولا قبل الامتحان
الحقيقي بعد عامين ان بقي على نيه الترشح
لا سيما انه يواجه ادنى نسبه تاييد
تاريخيه على الاطلاق والمخدره بثلاثه
وثلاثين في المئه
[موسيقى]
خطابات عده في تاريخ الكونجرس الامريكي
تتعاظم معتقادم الزمن حيث رسمت مسارات
حروب وانها اخرى ابرزها خطاب الرئيس
فرانكلين روزفلت الذي وصف بيوم العار
واعلن خلاله حاله الحرب على اليابان
عده وقفت على هذه المنصه تبعت محطات زمنيه
واحدث التغييرا جذريا بسير الازمات رؤساء
امريكيون اعتلوا منبر الكونغرس وادلب
خطابات حفرت في الذاكره احدها ادخل
الولايات المتحده الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ديسمبر
وان
الدايت
في الثامن من ديسمبر
1941 طلب الرئيس الثاني والثلاثون
فرانكلين روسفلت من الكونغرس اعلان الحرب
على اليابان اثر هجومي
على الصياغه ليبدا كلامه باليوم الذي
سيعيش في العار
50 عاما بعدها خطاب نصر ادلى به الرئيس
جورج بوش الاب في السابعه والعشرين من
فبراير
1991 اعلن خلاله تحرير الكويت اثرى عمليه
خاطفه اجبلت القوات العراقيه على الانسحاب
بالقوه من الاراضي الكويتيه بعد استنفاذ
جهود اقناع صدام حسين بالخروج الطوعيه
[تصفيق]
ا لكنه ايد عام 95 مع عرف بسياسه الرفع
والضربه في ما يخص حرب البوسنه متحدثا
بنبره غاضبه ممزوجته بالطاعه عاطف
مرحله اخرى رسمتها سبتمبر عام 2001 حرب
على الارهاب كما سماها الرئيس الاسبق جورج
بوش فصولها باستمرار
ماشي
في بعض الاحيان تصرفات عفويه او مقصوده
كما حصل مع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
حين مزقت رئيسه مجلس النواب نانسي
مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
تهديد روسي من نوع جديد ضربه نوويه
كهرومغناطيسيه قد تعطل الاسلحه الغربيه في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد امرت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بصحب قواتها من مدينه خرسون
الاوكرانيه وبرر وزير الدفاع روسي سرقه
القرار بتنظيم خطوط الدفاعي على نهر
النيبرو وتعد خرسون المنطقه الوحيده التي
سيطرت عليها بالكامل منذ بدء الهجوم على
اوكرانيا حيث عرفت المنطقه
بعد قيام الجيش الاوكراني هجمات مضاده على
القوات الروسيه
في المقابل قال مستشار الرئيس الاكراني
انه من المبكر جدا الحديث عن انسحاب
القوات الروسيه طالما لم ترفع اوكرانيا
علمها في المنطقه واكد بودلياك ان قوات
الروسيه ما زلت باقيه في خرسون ويتم الدفع
بقوات اخرى مشددا على ان القياده
الاخرانيه لا تعيره اهتماما للتصريحات
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني اهلا بك سيد
ياسين يعني هل فعلا حزمت المعركه في خرسون
ما الذي يحصل هناك بالتحديد
مساء الخير شكرا على
استضافتي تحيه منكيه
خبر عن انسحاب المختمل لقوات الروسيه من
خرسان قبل عده ساعات قبل اربع ساعات
تقريبا
ولكن صراحه نحن نفتكر هاي مش يعني شيء من
احساس بالنسبه
يعني كل شيء الان يتركز على نهر
في اوروبا
[موسيقى]
غربيه الشرقيه الان عند الروس وهم على
الضفه الغربيه عندهم زي يسمون العساكره
راس جسر في هذه المنطقه وفي في مدينه
خرسون كمان
منذ تقريبا اسبوعين ثلاثه او حتى اكثر كان
همم كانت اخبار بين الروس بعده
او زرع الغام حول خرسون وزاره الارقام في
ضفه الغربيه ولكن حتى زار الاغا الغام
بدهم خرائط
هذا الانسحاب الروسي هل سيقدم بوت اخر صون
فعليا كهديه للزلنسكي كما حصل في حركه
يعني هناك سيناريو عسكري يتحدث بانه هذا
الانسحاب ما هو الا تمهيد لاجلاء المدنيين
يعني تحضير اخلاء المدينه وتحضيرها لحرب
شوارع
انا برايبين مصاحب كاملين لم يعطي الى
اوكرانيا الان وفي يده غصن الزيتون
[موسيقى]
مكلف جدا في ما يخص الجنود والضبان
والخسائر والاخره الى اخره ثانيا كل
الجسور تقريبا عبر الديبروه في هذه مكان
همم
ظهر عريض جدا حوالي 100 حوالي واحد كيلو
واحد كيلو متر سوري من نهر من ناحيه
عسكريه حربيه من حساب تزويد قوات بالاسلحه
والاخيره ولكن
هناك ثلاثه روايات اول
روسيا انسحبون
روايه الثانيه هاي خلال عدو يعني
لماذا لينا بعد من نصاصه الاوكرانيين
يقولون اذا بدا روسيا تتحدث عن شيء ما وا
وفي النهايه ستعمل بالعكس عن العكس وثانيا
في بعض الاساس يقولون بينا مش ممكن ان نثق
الجارنا الشرقي الشمالي
خلينا ننتظر شويه وانا موافق ما مستشار مع
سيد الرئيس اييه
هو قال خلينا ننتظر ونشوف العالم
الاوكراني فوق خرسه شكرا جزيلا لك من
اكيافي
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني على هذه
المنتخب
[موسيقى]
تحديد النوويه الروسيه يشير الى احتمال
حصولي ضربه نوويه كهرومغناطيسيه تدمر
المعدات الدفاعيه التي نشرها النتو في
اوكرانيا وتعطل الدوائر الكهربائيه بشكل
كبير وفق ما كشفه تقرير
واطلاق مثل هذا السلاح فوق اوكرانيا
ايضا لانظمه حرب المعلومات
الكهرومغناطيسيه النوويه الصغيره مثل هذه
تنشرها بسهوله على ارتفاعات عاليه بواسطه
صواريخ كروز الروسيه زيركون التي تفوق
سرعتها سرعه الصوت ويمكن للتاثيرات
الكهرومغناطيسيه المتبقيه للضربه ان تدمر
90 بالمئه من الاقمار الصناعيه فوق
المنطقه المنكوبه في غضون ثلاثه اشهر ولكن
ما هي القنبله
مغناطيسيه هي سلاح تهدف الى تعطيل الاجهزه
الكترونيه من خلال النبضه المغناطيسيه
الكهربائيه الكبرى التي يمكنها التداخل مع
الاجهزه الكهربائيه والالكترونيه ونظم
تشغيلهم لالحاق اضرار فيهم واصابتهم
بالتلف وعاده ما تكون اثارها لا تتجاوز 10
كيلو متر من الانفجار اذا لم تكن مقترنه
بقنبله نوويه او ان تكون مصممه خصيصا
لانتاج هذه النبضات الكهرومغناطيسيه
الهائله تعتمد جميع المعدات الدفاعيه التي
نشرها حلفاء الناتو في اوكرانيا مثل اجهزه
الراديو ونظام تحديد المواقع العالمي
والطائرات جي بي اس والطائرات من دون طيار
على الالكترونيات وفي حال استخدمت روسيا
هذه القنبله الكهرومغناطيسيه سيتعين على
اوكرانيا وقت القتال مؤقتا لاعاده تخزين
تراسنتها المدمر ويمكن لبوتا اعاده بناء
قوته واعاده امدادها والاستيلاء على
المناطق واخلاء سكانها حديثا خلال هجوم
الربيع
[موسيقى]
البريطاني بنويلس ان بلاده تتجه لزياده
دعمها للجنود الاوكرانيين في الشتاء معلنا
تصميمه على تزويد القوات الاوكرانيه بافضل
المهارات الاساسيه على حد تعبيره ولس اضاف
ان اوكرانيا تحقق مكاسب في شرق البلاد
وتتقدم ببطء نحو خرصون في الجنوب
في المقابل اكد المتحدث باسم الكريم بان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن سيزور مدينه
دمباز الواقعه جنوب شرق اوكرانيا ديسكوفا
اوضح ايضا ان زياره بوتن لدوم باز غير
مخطط لها بالتحديده لكن بحسب وصفه دوم باس
مناطق روسيه وسياحين الوقت لسياراتها من
الرئيس فلاد اميركوتن
[موسيقى]
رغم دخول الاحتجاجات الايرانيه اسبوعها
الثامن رفض النظام الايراني تنظيم استفتاء
عام حول اصل النظافه ان التظاهرات تتراجع
وتدريجيا وفق ما اعلنه نائب الرئيس
الايراني للشؤون البرلمانيه محمد حسيني
بدوره حذر نائب الشؤون القانونيه للرئيس
الايراني محمد زهقانه من مساعي من سماهم
الاعداء لتجزئه ايران عبر الاطاحه بنظام
الحكم وعلى واقعه تصريحات الايرانيه رفع
طلاب ايران شعار عدونه هنا يكذب من يقول
انه في امريكا التظاهرات في الجامعات لم
تبدا بمواساه المسيرات الليليه في طهران
ومدن عزه رغم ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى اكثر
من 320 شخصا بينهم 50 طفلا في 136 مدينه
و158 جامعه شهدت الاحتجاجات
في المقابل وفي ظله تعنوت النظام الايراني
دعى التكتل الرئيسي للتيار الاصلاحي ولاول
مره دع السلطات الى تنظيم استفتاء للخروج
من الازمه الداخليه الناتجه عن الاحتجاجات
التي بدات قبل اسابيع في اعقاب مقتل
الشابه مهساينه وتضم الجبهه الاصلاحيه
التي طالبت بالاستفتاء شخصيات مقربه من
الرئيس السابق خاتمي كما حضرت الجبهه
الاصلاحيه السلطات على اجراء تغيرات
الفوريه تغيرات شجاعه وجريئه على حد وصفها
ايران تهدد بريطانيا بدفع ثمن افعالها
لجعلها ايران بلدا غير امن والسبب قناه
ايران انترناشونال في التفاصيل الشدد وزير
المخابرات الايراني اسماعيل الخطيب انه
سيعتبر اي نوع من الارتباط بهذه المؤسسه
الارهابيه دخول الى المجال الارهابي
وتهديدا للامن القومي على حسب قوله وزير
المخابرات الايراني اضاف قائلا لن ندعم
الاعمال الارهابيه في دول اخرى مثل
بريطانيا لكن لن يكون لدينا التزام بمنع
انعدام امها لذلك ستدفع المملكه المتحده
ثمن افعالها لجعل ايران بلدا غير امن وعقب
تهديد اثنين من صحفي ايران انترناشونال من
قبل الحرس الثوري الايراني ردد مساعد وزير
الخارجيه البريطانيه للشؤون الايرانيه
لتحديدات الصحفيين الايرانيين في بريطانيا
من قبل الحرس الثوري واكد ان بريطانيا
تفرض مجموعه من العقوبات ضد ايران وان هذه
العقوبات تحد من الانشطه من قبل النظام
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا حول هذه الاحتياجات في ايران
من لندن الباحث في الشان الايراني عارف
نصر اهلا بك سيد عارف يعني هناك طرح لي
استفتاء يمكن ان يقام بايران الماده 59
سيد عارف من الدستور الايراني تقول بانه
بالقضايا المهمه على الصعيد الاقتصادي
والسياسي وما الى ذلك يمكن ان تدعو القوه
التشريعيه يعني البرلمان الى استفتاء ولكن
شرط قبول ثلثي اعضائه
لكن الماده 94 من نفس الدستور تقول بانه
يجب الحصول على موافقه مجلس صيانه الدستور
اللي في 12 عضو سته منهم معينين من بطريقه
مباشره من المرشد والبقون هم حقيقيين
مقربين ايضا بمعنى
اسماء همم يعني همم تم همم طرح استفتاء
الذي يجب ان يقول نعم لهذا الاستفتاء هو
المرشد فهل سيعطي الضوء الاخضر لاجراء
الاستفتاء بهذا التوقيت بالذات
يه العربيه الكرام الواقع بان اذا ما
اردنا ان همم ربما الاجابه ان تكون
دستوريه ممكن ان نقول بان هنالك اربع مواد
رئيسيه من الدستور الايراني تتحدث عن
الاستفتاء هي الماده سته وكذلك همم 59
و110 و177 هناك عده نقاط مهمه بهذه المواد
همم المواد الثلاثه الباقيه تجعل المرشد
الايراني هو من يبادر بتعديلات الدستوريه
والماده الوحيده التي تتحدث عن ان السلطه
التشريعيه تستطيع ان تكون هي المبادره همم
ما هي الماده 59 المشكله كما تفضلت هي
الماده اولا 94 وحتى اليه فضل النزاع بين
البرلمان ومجلس صيانه الدستور تكون من
صلاحيات مجمع تشخيص مصلحه النظام الذي
يعين ايضا مرشد الايراني وبالتالي كل
الدروب تنتهي الى المرشد الايراني هذه
النقطه النقطه الثانيه نحن لا ننسى بان
البيان قبل ثلاثه ايام الذي صدر من 227
همم برلماني دعوا الى اعدام المتظاهرين
وبالتالي لا توجد هنالك حتى اذا ما كانت
هنالك اراده الى همم التغيير ثلثي الاعضاء
يريدون ربما الذهاب الى الاستفتاء عمليا
لا يمكن الغول ان ربما هذا الامر جزء همم
او ضمن الخيارات الا اذا كانت هنالك ربما
توافق من المرشد الايراني على لا يكون هو
من يبادر الى همم طرح الاستفتاء ويكون
ربما بالتنسيق مع البرلمان ان يدعو هؤلاء
الذين هم اشبه بالدمى ان يقومون بهذه
القضيه
سيد عارف يعني الاستفتاء الذي طرحه
الاصلاحيون هو ربما يعني يقال بانه
يعني تهدئه الشارع والحفاظ على هذا النظام
بالوقت اللي المحتجين رفعوا من سقف
مطالبهم ويريدون اسقاط هذا النظام هل
سيقبل الشارع بهذا الاستفتاء الذي يعني
ينظمه النظام ولنظام يعني ليس احد يعني
موضوعي اصلا والاهم هذا الدستور اصلا
الايراني هل هو مهيا للتنوع السياسي مهيئ
لاحزاب جديده تدخل الى العمليه السياسيه
لحريه الراي
طبعا لا الاجابه لا ولا كبيره خاصه اذا ما
قرات هذه الفقره ربما من ماده 177 تقول
التالي لا يجوز مطلقا تعديل مضامين المواد
المتعلقه بالطبيعه الاسلاميه للنظام
السياسي وقيام كل الغوانين والمقررات على
اساس الموازين الاسلاميه والاسس الدينيه
واهداف الجمهوريه
الايرانيه وكذلك المذهب الجعفري وولايه
الفقيه بمعنى كل كل ربما المواد التي يجب
ان يكون عليها الاستفتاء يجب ان لا تتضمن
هذه الامور وبما في ذلك حتى مساله الحجاب
باعتبارها ربما الجزء الموازين الاسلاميه
تفسر من هنا اعتقد بان كل الاجراءات حتى
اذا ما كانت ربما الذهاب الى الى مبدا
الاستفتاء الذي ضمنه هو كفله الدستور لا
تشمل هذه القضايا الاساسيه التي يطالب بها
المحتجون وبالتالي الدروب ربما ااه
لاجراء اصلاحات جذريه التي طالب بها حتى
حفيد الخميني حسن خميني وكذلك الاصلاحين
ربما لا تكون عبره الدستور وحده الا اذا
ما كانت هنالك اراده يا كبيره تدعو الى
التخلي من نظام ولايه الفقير بربك شكرا
جزيلا لك من لندن الباحثه في شان الايراني
يعرف نفسه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
صراع امريكيه روسي على نفط سوريا باعياد
الاشياء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلانات مجموعهما التي
تضم شركات فيسبوك انستقرام واتساب عن
تسريح ثلاثه عشر بالمئه من موظفيها حول
العالم وفقا لبيان رئيسها التنفي ذكر بريك
فانا القرار يعد من اصعب التغييرات التي
اتخذ في تاريخ الشركه
على خطط وتر تسير متى نحو احد عشر الف
موظف في طريقهم لفقد وظائفهم بعد قرار
رئيس الشركه مارك زوكربيرج عاصفه سلكون
فالي تطالب ميتا في فتره مضطربه تمر بها
الشركه حيث فقدت مليارات الدولارات من
قيمه اسهم هذا العام تراجع اداء ميتا عكسه
تباطؤ نموره عالميا في مواجهه تيك توك
التي تتصاعد بقوه في عالم الشبكات
الاجتماعيه الى جانب تراجع عدد من
المعلمين الرقميين عن الانفاق على منصات
الشركه بسبب ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وعدم
استقرار الاسواق عمليه تسريحتها تعد
الاكبر من نوعها في تاريخ الشركه البالغ
عدد موظفها 87.000 وهو ما دفع مارك
زوربيرج الى مخاطبه الموظفين في رساله
ممزوجه بمسحه اعتذار ووعود بالاصلاح
اريد ان اتحمل المسؤوليه عن هذه القرارات
وكيف وصلنا الى هنا اعرف ان هذا صعب على
الجميع وانا اسف بشكل خاص للمتاثرين
قرارات اضافيه تتجه مثل اتخاذها وفق بيان
مركز كربرج من بينها ان تصبح الشركه اصغر
حجما واكثر كفاءه من خلال خفض الانفاق الى
جانب تمديد قرار وقف عمليات التوظيف
وفقا لخبراء فان قرارات ذكر اللورد تتعارض
مع نيته زياده الانفاق والتوسع في بناء
عالم متوفرز الافتراضي والاستثمار في
ادواته التقنيه
نهج جديد في اداره كبرى الشركات
التكنولوجيه العملاقه قد يلحق بركبه اخرون
لكنه في الوقت ذاته يعكس اختبارا صعبا
ورهنا قد تظهر نتائجها اما الخروج من
الازمه او مزيد من القرارات الصعبه علي
السمان العربيه
[موسيقى]
الثاني عشر مع استمرار الصراع الامريكيه
الروسيه للسيطره على امكانيات سوريا
من الحقول والمنشات الواقعه بشكل رئيسي في
شمال شرق سوريا حوالي 400 الف برميل يوميا
قبل بدء الصراع وبعد انديلاعه عام 2011
سيطرت قوى متناحره مختلفه بما في ذلك
فصائل من المعارضه وتنظيم داعش على جزء
كبير من هذه الثروه النصيه فالعقبات
الغربيه المفروضه على قطاع النفس السوري
دفعت بشركات النفط الاجنبيه لمغادره
البلاد في الوقت الراهن تسيطر قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وهي عباره عن ائتلاف مدعوم من
الولايات المتحده على ربع الاراضي السوريه
بما في ذلك من طاقه شرق الفرات الغنيه
بالنفط غاز مما يعني ان قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه بدعم امريكيه تسيطر الان على
90% من النفط واكثر من 50 بالمئه من حقول
الغاز الطبيعي في المقابل اعلن النظام
السوري ان خسائر القطاع النفط منذ بدايه
الازمه بلغت اكثر من 90 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]
خلال المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقده في تولون
بجنوب فرنسا قال الرئيس الفرنسي
يساهم في امن فرنسا واوروبا مؤكدا على
ضروره ضبط النفس فيما يتعلق بالرضع النووي
للحفاظ على المستقيم
هو شغل جديد
يقعدونه
ابيض
[موسيقى]
اكثر من مليون شخص اليها قبل سبع سنوات
في اغسطس الماضي في 27 دوله في الاتحاد
الاوروبي فيما طلبه حوالي
255,000 غالبيتهم من اوكرانيا شكلا من
اشكال الحمايه المؤقته بزياده تصل الى 16%
مقارنه بشهر يوليو
تم اغلاق مفعل في محطه طاقه النوويه جنوب
السويد بشكل غير متوقع بعد عطل في تربين
حسب ما اعلنت هيئه البث السويدي الرسميه
واوضح حتى المتحدثه باسم المحطه ان
المفاعل الثالث في محطه اوسكار شمال
للطاقه النوويه فصل عن شبكه الطاقه بسبب
التوقف التوربين وان العمل جار لحل
المشكله
9 الحكومه الاوكرانيه في اعاده بناء اكبر
طائره شحن في العالم بعد ان دمرت من قبل
القوات الروسيه عبر مروحياتها الطائره
التي تستطيع حمل 250 طن من مواد الشحن
ظهرت وهي مدمر بالكامل
امامي اكبر طائره شحن في العالم وهي
انطونيو 225 التي يبلغ طولها اكثر من 84
مترا وتستطيع حمل 250 طن من عمليات الشحن
هذه الطائره التي دمرت من قبل القوات
الروسيه عندما دخلت مدينه كوستاريل
الواقعه شمال العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
مستر دينالي رودينيك لو يحدثنا او تحدثنا
عن كيف قامت القوات الروسيه بتدمير هذه
الطائره
بدات روسيا عمليات عسكريه جوا استعدادا
لدخول كيف لكن القوات الاوكرانيه منعتهم
وقبل انسحابهم دمروا العديد من الطائرات
كما اجبروا احدى طائرات الشحن على الهبوط
الطائره المزوده ب6 محركات وزن كل محرك
يصل الى اكثر من 5500 كلغ وكذلك مزوده ب
40 عجله السيد فولدوير السومه وهو مهندس
تكنيكي لهذه الطائره تحدثنا عن التكنيك
لهذه الطائره وكيف اصبحت حطها في شو اسمه
خوري مجهزه
لكن لا نستطيع اصلاحها وتحتاج عملا كبيرا
ووقطا طويلا
تحاول اعاده بناء وصيانه هذه الطائره
الجديده رغم انها مدمره بشكل كامل
مع حديثها على قدرتها بناء طائره حديثه
وجديده اذا دعمتها الحكومه الاوكرانيه
لقناتي العربيه والحدثان الصفيان جوستومال
شمال
جورجيا
انسحاب مفاجئ للقوات الروسيه من خرسون
المنطقه الوحيده التي سيطرت عليها بالكامل
منذ بدل الهجوم في اوكرانيا
جبهه اصلاحيه داخل ايران تدعو السلطات
لاجراء استفتاء لاخراج البلاد من اثمتها
كبار ومواقع التواصل يا النون بعد تويتر
متى تسرح احد عشر الف موظفا بعد خسرتها
مليارات الدولارات هذا العام